[Musica]
ehi ciao coniglio ciao resto lasciami
entrare nel favoloso mondo delle
meraviglie ordinari d'aste tutti quanti
buongiorno
beh la conoscete tutti la storia spero
quella di alice favoloso mondo delle
meraviglie dello stregatto dei palmi per
i del cappellaio matto del bianconiglio
ve ne avete visto edilizio naturalmente
beh io non sono cosi per sorprendervi o
su stupirvi con incantesimi e magie che
non mi appartengono affatto ma
semplicemente per raccontarvi la mia
storia che è molto vicina a quella di
alice e al tempo delle fiabe per
iniziare mi piacerebbe tanto così ancora
per rendervi più partecipi far rientrare
proprio in questo mondo mi piacerebbe un
alzata di mano visto che avete visto
questo video capire tra i presenti in
sala chi si riconosce quotidianamente in
alice e chi nel coniglio bianco vediamo
quante quanti conigli bianchi ci sono
abbastanza e quante alice ok dice poker
ice presenti in sala anche il coniglio
bianco al suo perché dunque alice perché
le fiabe le fiabe perché perché potrei
dirvi che io come alice sono affetta da
sempre sin da bambina da quella malattia
incurabile che quella di sognare ad
occhi aperti e da sempre e questo
sognare ad occhi aperti nel tempo mi ha
portato poi a scelte radicali molto
importanti come quella di un anno fa di
licenziarmi mollare un lavoro sicuro un
lavoro in un'azienda strutturata avevo
un favoloso contratto di lavoro a tempo
indeterminato ma che oggi dà molta
sicurezza e per dirla tutta stavo anche
molto bene in questo posto di lavoro ma
non era più il mio mondo non era più il
mio mondo favoloso che sognavo da sempre
quindi questo sognare continuo sin da
bambina mi ha portato nel tempo a
prendere questa scelta radicare un anno
fa e per che cosa per realizzare il mio
sogno più grande che è quello dopo di
essere diventata madre perché sono
diventata mamma
in quasi otto anni fa che era quello di
aprire un centro polifunzionale che io
definisco il centro polifunzionale delle
meraviglie perché questo è a tutti gli
effetti centro polifunzionale che cosa
si intende per che oggi quando lo
racconto ancora vedo che la gente fa una
faccia un po strana centro
polifunzionale è un luogo di lavoro in
primis che mette insieme le persone per
farle lavorare
mette insieme più progettualità mette
insieme adulti bambini mette insieme
mondo profit e no profit mette insieme i
sogni crea contatti perché la vita è
fatta di incontri di contatti tra le
persone anche con le cose se questo
toccarsi alle volte è così magico e così
fantastico che è come un toccarsi fra
stelle e succedono scintille veramente e
così nel mio spazio polifunzionale che
cosa succede ogni giorno e stupore e
meraviglia allo stato puro e tutto
questo avviene sicuramente perché perché
gli spazi e quindi non solo le persone e
le idee sono veramente perfetti sono
spazi che da tempo non aspettavano che
questo perché il tutto avviene in una
casa aiuta sempre sognavo di fare quello
che sto facendo in una casa e ho avuto
la grandissima fortuna di trovare una
casa perfetta che proprio si è si adatta
perfettamente a tutto quello che avevo
in testa è una casa che ecco la c
maiuscola e bellezza ovunque si guardi
non lo dico io lo dicono i testi perché
questa casa e su tutti i testi di
architettura è stata costruita
nell'immediato dopoguerra da un
grandissimo architetto friulano angelo
mazzieri nel 49 terminata nel 51 quando
ancora in udine intorno c'erano le
macerie della guerra
questa casa per tanti anni è stata la
casa di abitazione di una famiglia e poi
nel tempo le cose sono cambiate le
situazioni sono cambiate a questa casa
da circa tre anni era disabitata e io
per puro caso il favoloso caso che cosa
volte no succede
ho avuto la fortuna di incontrare questo
caso lei ha incontrato me ci siamo
proprio incontrati nel momento giusto
che poi le cose accadono quando devono
avvenire stupore meraviglia dovunque si
guardi io vi farò vedere qualche
immagine ma credetemi le immagini non
rendono la bellezza di questo luogo che
che cosa consente consente che le
persone arrivino vengano per lavorare
liberi professionisti di diverso genere
oppure vengano per per stare insieme
semplicemente fra le persone adulti e
bambini insieme o vengono semplicemente
perché facciamo delle proposte di
percorsi di crescita e percorsi di
benessere per far star bene le persone
perché le persone hanno bisogno di stare
bene e in un luogo di bellezza tutto
questo è ancora più semplice e quindi
abbiamo una cucina come tutte le case
che un po il cuore della casa dove
quando vogliamo possiamo darci
prepararsi da mangiare farci un caffè e
stare insieme e fuori fuori poi è uno
splendore anche fuori quindi c'era tanto
verde ci sono alberi alberi che hanno
oltre 60 anni raccontano anche solo loro
chissà quante cose non volervi anche
solo guardare e quindi è veramente così
è proprio stupore meraviglia ovunque si
guardi tutto questo agevola agevola
tantissimo lo stare bene fra le persone
che era quello che io desideravo da
sempre creare un contenitore per far
star bene le persone per farle lavorare
bene in armonia ed è così noi lì ogni
giorno stiamo bene insieme
tra le persone fra di noi coesi uniti
tutti con questa convinzione che lo
stare insieme è la differenza fa la
differenza ecco questa foto poi la
lascia un attimo di sfondo perché è
significativa anche di una scelta che ho
voluto
affrontare in questa casa e che già vi
dà l'input di che cosa significa stare
in questa casa e della concezione del
tempo che c'è in questa casa che un
luogo di lavoro ne stiamo in ciabatte o
a piedi scalzi
nella prima regoletta quando si entra in
casa questo non solo per una così per un
rispetto del luogo e per una regola
igienica perché non serve che vi spieghi
ho tutto quello che portiamo sotto le
scarpe no ma anche ma fondamentalmente
perché perché è il primo proprio segnale
che qua dentro
in questo luogo di lavoro lo spazio il
tempo si dilata talmente tanto e questo
viene consentito anche dal semplice
gesto di togliersi le scarpe che tempo
fa più si dilata non ci si rende conto
di quanto tempo sia passando
effettivamente immagino che tutti di voi
tutti voi stasera quando arriverete a
casa la prima cosa che farete vi
toglierete le scarpe
chissà quanti tra i presenti in sala non
vedono già l'ora di farlo perché insomma
tenere piede costretto in queste scarpe
non è poi così piacevole quindi
immaginate in un ambiente di lavoro
dovrebbe provare magari qualche azienda
perché certo non in tutti gli ambienti
di lavoro questo è possibile però in
molti si è un'educazione che si può
acquisire in primis a casa e poi nel
proprio ambiente di lavoro è una scelta
così come ho scelto proprio perché le
fiabe da sempre appartengono al mio
nutrimento personale di avere
all'interno di questa casa immagini che
appartengono al mondo delle fiabe
appartengono al mondo delle
illustrazioni dei racconti e sono
immagini che comunicano molto più di
tante belle parole
questa in primis è un'immagine che
all'interno della casa e che comunica
proprio quello che vogliamo portare in
questo spazio di lavoro come concetto
fondamentale perché la gente che viene
in questo spazio di lavoro è arriva per
prendersi del tempo e per prendersi cura
di sé sia che sia per lavorare in un
ambiente estremamente piacevole sia che
sia semplicemente per staccare la spina
vengo lì perché ho bisogno
ho bisogno di staccare la spina e di
arrivare in questa piccola oasi di pace
che ha proprio nel cuore di udine e
quindi questa immagine che porta proprio
la mano verso il cuore è quello che
stiamo facendo nel concreto dopo anni e
anni e anni di tanto fantasticare tanto
sognare sei anni per l'esattezza e
anch'io come alice vi posso garantire
che mi sono sentita mi sono trovata come
lei confusa ma non saper dove andare che
strada pigliare e soprattutto nessuno
trovata anche io come alice molte volte
a piangere a piangere perché
fondamentalmente perché mi ostinavo a
voler far capire alle persone quello che
avevo in testa e far capire alle persone
un progetto così complesso non è molto
semplice soprattutto quando questo
progetto è solo ancora nella mia testa
era ancora nella mia testa e non è
ancora tangibile non lo si può vedere e
mi arrabbiavo da morire mi sono fatta
tanti pianti fino a quando ho detto
basta basta fine rose irmi basta tutto
questo voler per forza far capire agli
altri quello che nella mia testa
quindi cosa ci vuole ci vuole un
cambiamento e questo cambiamento può
avvenire solo dopo un periodo di calma
un periodo di silenzio nel quale si è
per lo meno io ho compreso che il mio
mondo favoloso che era quello delle
fiabe si può concretamente portare poi
nella vita reale e questa immagine che
l'immagine che c'è l'ingresso del della
casa dell'immagine che meglio proprio
trasmette questo concetto è che molto
rimanda anche al mondo di alice dove
tutto è sottosopra e allo specchio dove
la logica el analogica dove l'adulto e
il bambino l'alto e basso piccola e
grande si contrappongono ma anche se
corrispondono questo è possibile
realizzarlo concretamente bisogna
volerlo bisogna cominciare a guardare il
mondo con occhi diversi da una
prospettiva diversa
come comunica chiaramente questa
immagine in primis volerle questa
immagine stava sotto un bellissimo
calendario con una frase famosa di cerci
che diceva che dice non sempre cambiare
equivale a migliorare ma per migliorare
bisogna cambiare questa fase mi ha
inseguito per mesi prima di affrontare
questo cambiamento
fino a che poi ho detto è arrivato il
momento
silvia sei pronta sei pronta e tutto
questo essere pronta parte da che cosa
però parte da una scelta che viene
ancora a monte parte da una scelta
ma che è stata ancora tanti anni fa si
sceglie si sceglie che cosa si vuole
fare nella vita
che ruolo se vuole avere nella vita ma
soprattutto si sceglie se se voci si
vuole stupirsi
sì io ho scelto che poi essere al mondo
per stupirmi ma perché ho scelto questo
perchè mi sono accorta negli anni che
c'è motivo di stupirsi
ogni giorno ogni giorno se sappiamo
guardare il mondo con gli occhi del
mondo favoloso che ci educano le fiabe e
racconti i cartoni animati
io sono nata e cresciuta con le fiabe
con i racconti e questo mi hanno
insegnato ancora mi nutro di fiabe di
racconti e di cartoni animati e questo
mi insegnano che ci si può stupire
meravigliare ogni giorno perché
l'immedesimarsi poi nell'eroe nella
principessa chi di noi non l'ha mai
fatto da bambini non posso credere che
nessuno di voi non l'abbia mai fatto
leggendo o ascoltando un racconto
immedesimarsi in un ruolo fantastico e
favoloso aiuta agevola la vita e ci fa
affrontare le cose in un modo molto più
semplice che quello che appartiene al
mondo delle fiabe al tempo delle fiabe
ma poi si può lo si può portare anche
alla vita di tutti i giorni
le fiabe dovremmo riprenderla in mano un
po tutti da adulti e quindi non solo
educare i bambini è molto semplice con i
bambini molto più diretto noi da adulti
dobbiamo riprenderci in mano le fiabe o
guardare più cartoni animati perché le
fiabe cartoni hanno molto da molto da
trasmetterci tutto questo sicuramente è
una parte che comunque credo sia un po
innata in me da sempre e quindi tutto
questo essere in me innato questo mondo
questo sentire
di appartenere sia al mondo reale ma
anche a qualcosa di favoloso che non è
tangibile
sicuramente in mera innato e questo
essere innato poi non lascia spazio
indugi e quindi quando giunge il momento
è il momento di agire
vorrei dirvi anche questo che il sognare
ad occhi aperti non significa essere
fuori dal mondo valori sottolineo anche
se io mi sono sentita dire per molti
anni spesso e volentieri ma cosa fa
questa mai pazza ma che idea in testa ma
chi glielo fa fare
più e più volte me lo sono sentita dire
è d'accordo
ok ho lasciato correre ho smesso di
continuare a sentire fermarmi allo
stesso sentire queste voci e ho pensato
semplicemente di seguire quello che era
dentro di me quello che mi diceva
l'istinto silvia il tuo mondo e quello
cerca di realizzarlo riportarlo nel
concreto e così ho fatto ho realizzato
un luogo dove appunto le persone adulti
e bambini si incontrano creiamo progetti
creiamo proposte di crescita di
benessere e le persone stanno bene
stanno talmente bene che veramente vi
garantisco il tempo passa ma non ci si
rende conto di quanto tempo
effettivamente stia passando e poi
fondamentalmente perché no
perché non farlo perché non creare
qualche cosa di bello che fa star bene
le persone
un sì quando e si risponde sì ad un
altro si vede stato così e questo parte
ancora da un cammino mio personale che
poi porto dentro questo insieme questo
spazio di insieme che è iniziato dieci
anni fa quando sono partita per il
giappone per un'esperienza di
volontariato conosciuta per caso perché
casualmente ho conosciuto il servizio
civile internazionale e questo paese da
sempre mi chiamava perché poi succede
anche così le cose ti chiamano e poi
bisogna effettivamente seguirle e così
ho fatto
sono partita per questo paese che da
anni mi chiamava ma non volevo andare in
questo paese come una classica turista e
soprattutto per tutto anche non potevo
permettermelo
perché un paese alquanto impegnativo e
quindi ho detto sparto e molte persone
mia madre compresa la dicevano pensavano
dio questo non torna più questo rimane
la e invece no sono partita ho fatto
questa bellissima esperienza di
volontariato e sono tornata con proprio
quello di cui avevo bisogno che era il
motore per tornare fa reagire qua nel
mio paese quel paese sa cosa mi ha
insegnato fondamentalmente mi ha
insegnato una cosa bellissima che è il
senso di gratitudine
devo ringraziare perché sono una persona
estremamente fortunata fortunata perché
ho ricevuto tanto e in primis ho
ricevuto ho avuto sempre la possibilità
di scegliere di scegliere quello che
volevo fare che è una grandissima
libertà di scegliere che esperienza fare
di scegliere che lavoro fare
e questa libertà sicuramente non è da
tutti è una libertà che comunque anche
ci si conquista si si conquista anche
con lacrime e con qualche porta chiusa
in faccia più d'una è una libertà che
poi nel tempo comunque poi una volta
diventata madre
ahimé devo dire ho sentito meno perché a
quel tempo sono diventata madre ed ero
libera professionista ed essere madre e
libera professionista insieme non è poi
una passeggiata io sono anche stata
fortunata perchè perchè avevo due nonne
favolose le ho ancora mi potevano
garantire un supporto che non tutti
obiettivamente hanno però vi garantisco
che lasciare il proprio figlio a tre
mesi per dover tornare a lavorare perché
così è stato non è stata cosa semplice
quindi sarà poco da lasciarsi incantare
dallo sguardo del proprio bambino non
c'era tempo e dentro di me è cominciato
proprio in quel momento credo a nascere
questo desiderio di creare un qualche
cosa di diverso livello lavorativo dove
si potesse coniugare il tempo famiglia
le necessità che una famiglia un né un
genio genitore a con un bambino
soprattutto piccolo con una dimensione
lavorativa che consenta di vivere
insieme al proprio figlio e questo è
possibile quindi in cui in questo spazio
di lavoro che ho creato è possibile
lavorare e contemporaneamente per chi
vuole avere proprio figlio in età di
nido a pochi passi dal proprio ufficio
con un educatrice in uno spazio in tutta
sicurezza
ma la tua misura di bambino e quindi
lavorare serenamente
con i tempi e la voglia di maternità è
possibile questo dovrebbe essere più
possibile in più realtà in più aziende e
fondamentalmente questo è stato perché
perché c'è sempre stato un pensiero in
me
costruito nel tempo dalle esperienze di
volontariato che poi ho anche aperta
un'associazione di volontariato e per
dieci anni non ci siamo occupati di
progetti di sostegno alla genitorialità
e l'infanzia
adesso questa associazione cresce e si
sviluppa ogni giorno dentro lo spazio di
lavoro che ho creato perché credo
fondamentalmente che il mondo profit del
mondo no profit debbano stare insieme
per creare sviluppo e progettualità
nuove perché se diffondiamo cose belle
il mondo si occupa di portare cose
ancora migliori ed è proprio così nella
mia vita è sempre stato così o diffuse
ho creato tantissime belle cose di cui
la gente ancora oggi mi ringrazia ma me
ne sono arrivate sempre molte di più per
questo che io devo dire grazie
ogni giorno e lo dico effettivamente
dico grazie per tutto quello che ho
ricevuto grazie per le possibilità che
mi stanno arrivando e per le persone che
sono insieme con me che credono in
questo modo di stare insieme perché
questo è possibile
quindi questo spazio di insieme può
venire da un sogno da un sogno che penn
sito basta che uno di voi sogni come ho
fatto io che si ispiri guardando il
cielo guardando la luna che poi pro
torni nel proprio silenzio a guardare la
terra perché i sogni si possono
realizzare
quindi mi auguro veramente di avere
anche solo un po contagiato qualcuno di
voi perché magari chi lo sa nei prossimi
giorni nei prossimi mesi qualcuno di voi
possa veramente concretizzare i propri
sogni come ho fatto io
[Musica]
grazie per avermi ascoltato abbiate cura
dei vostri sogni prendetevi il tempo
perché i sogni hanno bisogno di tempo
per essere poi realizzati grazie
[Applauso]